I had so much fun with that baby bump
balls down the stairs and guys like he
got what when she pulls out the decayed
arm don't go buy a Rolex
if you ever win the lottery or something
just take it step by step we don't need
any of this this house wants to us now
I'm not gonna let anybody take that away
from us I'm calling the police
no you guys let's talk about dangerous
lives the movie is out so we get to dive
right into the spoilers my favorite part
first off
Cammie what was it like for you to rock
that baby bug oh my god I had so much
fun with that baby bump and I really
hope that it's not too early to post
some content that I have with the baby
bump like I probably am gonna post it
because it's so good Jesse you know what
I'm talking about right I know exactly
what you're talking about I remember
when I was walking around with a baby
bump I did everything I possibly could
how did you feel with that last time
jump in and seen that Katie was pregnant
she kind of got her own little happy
ending
it's a much-needed happy ending it's not
you know there's still a lot of things
that are tragic about it you know she no
longer has her love in her life and
she's alone in this big house so I think
there's like a darker note to it but I
like that the film ends on something a
little hopeful not just that she has
like new life that she's bringing new
life into the world but also that those
diamonds are there in the soil and you
kind of are left wondering like is she
ever gonna find them or not Jessie how
did you feel watching that seeing that
the diamonds are in the dirt when Adam
so clearly said they're in the garden
babe as his last words there's a lot
going on you know I can't I can't blame
her for not understanding what that
meant exactly if it was me personally
like if Jessie was in that situation out
of I would have said look go to the
trees start digging and some diamonds
right there how did it laid it out but
you know for some reason Adam decided to
leave a faint encrypted message for his
wife and there's a lot of cars a big
garden there's a lot vegetation
yeah maybe she would heat her garden and
that's why she's been working that she
just hasn't gotten there yet yeah there
are a lot of no there there no no not a
good point I do know that this movie had
way more twists than I was expecting
you guys were initially reading the
script which twist really threw you for
a loop the most when she pulls out the
decayed arm and old diamonds I think
that was like the most intriguing to me
I don't know exactly what his role is
but the guy who was like your boss when
he breaks into the house and then alden
breaks his neck that was the most
intriguing part to me that seemed like
the most mr. Calvin yeah like I seem
like the most outlandish twist that
could have possibly happened in that
moment I was like he just falls down the
stairs and dies like he got Jessie
you're like I can't believe that
happened and Kami's like oh I'm on
Riverdale that tracks no kami we've been
getting some music from you you did a
gorgeous cover of Mac Miller circles is
this something that you could be getting
more from you and would you ever want to
dip your toe more into music full-time
no actually I don't really see music as
something I'm never gonna pursue for
real I just I just like doing it mostly
for myself I get too nervous supposed to
share videos with me singing I find it
to be cringy sometimes watching myself
saying so I just it's really it's really
hard for me to actually post it so I
don't ever see myself pursuing it in a
serious way but every once in a while I
do something that I'm like I want to
share this Jessie I did a little deep
dive into your background and you know
your way around the kitchen have you
been making any fun Quarantine creations
these days I mean my daughter gets
pretty creative we do I started I
started this corn team like going heavy
into the grocery shopping and like
getting a crazy array of ingredients and
just like making really hits
who the dishes that were completely
unnecessary took way too long but it was
like occupying my time but then now what
it's become as more so just like me and
my daughter playing around in the
kitchen so like we go get baked goods
and I'm teaching her to make cupcakes
and stuff like that she's only three so
we've you know we keep it pretty simple
but she's pretty much an omelet master
now she's really good at making
milkshakes stuff like that that's more
so what has become it's like a thing for
her and I to do now that fans have
watched dangerous lies they've been on
this crazy journey what do you want to
say to them now that they've finished
anything you want to explain about that
ending yeah find the kind of money don't
go buy a Rolex yeah if you ever win the
lottery or something amazing happens to
you just take it step by step you know
don't go crazy hire a lawyer first
number one tell your wife everything
oh wait and also real quick Jesse did
you ever figure out who hit you in the
back yeah I mean we we know is the
audience but Adam and Katie I don't
think ever find out yeah we know like
the perception but honestly we're just
blaming everybody for everything we know
it's not me so where's the point fingers
at everybody else something tells me it
was Julia thank you guys so much for
your time Jesse it was such a pleasure
to meet you Cammie I adore you so much
and thank you so much for this fun movie
guys pretty clean
[Music]